[OCEAN WAVES]
♪ [VOCALIZING] ♪
♪ LIFT ME UP ♪
♪ HOLD ME DOWN ♪
♪ KEEP ME CLOSE ♪
♪ SAFE AND SOUND ♪
♪ BURNING IN A HOPELESS DREAM ♪
♪ HOLD ME WHEN YOU GO TO SLEEP ♪
♪ KEEP ME IN THE WARMTH OF
YOUR LOVE ♪
♪ WHEN YOU DEPART KEEP ME SAFE
SAFE AND SOUND ♪
♪ LIFT ME UP ♪
♪ HOLD ME DOWN ♪
♪ KEEP ME CLOSE ♪
♪ SAFE AND SOUND ♪
♪ DROWNING IN AN ENDLESS SEA ♪
♪ TAKE SOME TIME
AND STAY WITH ME ♪
♪ KEEP ME IN THE STRENGTH OF
YOUR ARMS ♪
♪ KEEP ME SAFE ♪
♪ SAFE AND SOUND ♪
♪ LIFT ME UP ♪
♪ HOLD ME DOWN (HOLD ME DOWN) ♪
♪ KEEP ME SAFE (KEEP ME CLOSE) ♪
♪ SAFE AND SOUND
(SAFE AND SOUND) ♪
♪ BURNING IN A HOPELESS DREAM ♪
♪ HOLD ME WHEN YOU GO TO SLEEP ♪
♪ KEEP ME SAFE ♪
♪ WE NEED LIGHT
WE NEED LOVE ♪
♪ LIFT ME UP
(HOLD ME, IN YOUR ARMS) ♪
♪ HOLD ME DOWN (I NEED LOVE,
I NEED LOVE, I NEED LOVE) ♪
♪ KEEP ME CLOSE (HOLD ME,
HOLD ME, DOWN) ♪
♪ SAFE AND SOUND (HOLD ME,
HOLD ME, HOLD ME, HOLD ME) ♪
♪ LIFT ME UP (HOLD
ME, HOLD ME) ♪
♪ HOLD ME DOWN (HOLD ME,
HOLD ME, HOLD ME, HOLD ME) ♪
♪ KEEP ME SAFE ♪
♪ WE NEED LIGHT ♪
♪ WE NEED LOVE ♪